[Music]
in today's eight on your side if you
need a safe place to dispose of your
e-waste we've got several
it's the u-break ifix block apparently
free tech recycling is available
at you break at fixed locations
throughout southern nevada we caught up
with the franchisee of the locations in
summerlin henderson in north las vegas
who says this is part of the company's
erase e-waste challenge in recognition
of earth day
they want you to sort through your old
electronics drop them off at their
location so
they don't wind up in our landfills the
franchisees
we saw this was an issue but at the
corporate level we just didn't really
have the resources to get it done
um so that's why when we reached out to
samsung samsung's always been a great
partner to us and they
they offered to facilitate free
recycling for all customers not just
samsung customers any customers of you
break ifix
um so we're really excited for that i
finally have a way to give people uh an
avenue to recycle their devices rather
than just you know toss them away and
hopefully it's an easy way because we do
have a lot of locations across the
country and across vegas
prior to the pandemic the united nations
global e-waste monitor
reported a record 53 million metric tons
of electronic waste
that's equivalent to 350 cruise ships
worth
so we've all got to do our part and
recycle